نتحدث اسرائيليا وفق الاعلان الاسرائيلي
في ان هناك اربع كتائب تابعه لكتائب
القسام في في رفح في منطقه رفح هذا موضوع
عسكري مهم وفق ما قالت اسرائيل ولكن هناك
جانب سياسي مهم في موضوع او جانب انساني
مهم في موضوع رفح اذ اننا نتحدث عن منطقه
منطقه لا تتجاوز
63 مربع منطقه رفح بهذا الشكل تقريبا اذا
ما رسمنا خريطه لرفح فهي بهذا الشكل
تقريبا من عند شارع الرشيد بالجهه الشرق
الجهه الغربيه الى الجنوب هذه منطقه رفح
عندما نتحدث عن رفح فنحن نتحدث عن المنطقه
الاكثر اكتظاظا بالسكان كان فيها 230,000
نسمه قبل الحرب الان وصل العدد الى مليون
و300 ال نسمه زياده كبيره جدا وهائل جدا
في عدد السكان في مدينه رفح لانه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي التي طلبت من
السكان من المناطق الشماليه التوجه نحو
رفح والتوجه نحو المواصي بدرجه اساسيه في
هذه المنطقه المنطقه الساحليه منطقه
المواصل التي تمتد من خانيونس وحتى رفح
ولكن اذا ما قارنا بعض الصور وصلت صور
للاقمار الصناعيه ومن الخامس من فبراير
وتحديدا في هذه المنطقه المنطقه منطقه
مخيم تل السلطان كما نشاهد على الخريطه
هذه الصور هي صور للخامس من فبراير وهذه
الخريطه هي الخريطه التي نتحدث عنها هذه
المنطقه دعوني اخذ هذا المربع فقط الذي
نشاهده على الخريطه ونلاحظ كميه عدد
السكان وعدد الخيم المرتفعه في الصوره
التي على اليسار والتي التقطت من الاقمار
الصناعيه يوم الخامس فبراير هاتان
الصورتان تعطينا مؤشرا عن عن الزياده
السكانيه الكبيره في منطقه خان يونس في
منطقه رفح نتحدث عن من
230,000 فلسطيني الى مليون و300 ال
فلسطيني اعداد كبيره وهائل جدا من الخيام
طبعا اذا ما انتقلنا الى صور اخرى فنحن
نتحدث عن مشاهد من الازدحام بالنازحين في
كل شوارع رفح التي امتلات تقريبا باكثر من
50% من عدد سكان قطاع غزه هذا يعني عسكريا
ان التوغل في رفح يعني ان هناك كارثه
انسانيه ستكون في هذه المنطقه اذا ما
تحدثنا عن المناطق التي يريد الاحتلال
التوغل بها في هذه المنطقه فنحن نتحدث عن
خيارات التوغل يمكن ان تكون من الجهه
الشرقيه وهي الجهه عمليا هي جهه رخوه
نسبيا لانها تاريخيا هي فارغه من السكان
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا ايضا
متوغل في هذه المنطقه منطقه تشكت الصوفي
الى الشرق من شارع صلاح الدين هي بطبيعه
الحال متوغل متوغل ايضا من جهه خزاعه
والفخار بهذا الشكل متوغل من الجهه
الشماليه من جهه خانيونس بمحاذاه شارع
صلاح الدين ولكن الدخول الى هذا المربع او
هذه الدائره هي هو دخول وسط مليون و300 ال
انسان هذا يعني ان هذا ال قول لن يكون
سهلا بطبيعه الحال لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ولن يكون سهلا ايضا على
الفلسطينيين الذين يتكدسون بمئات الالاف
في هذه المنطقه الصغيره للغايه نتحدث عن
حوالي 63 م م مربع فقط فيها مليون و300 ال
انسان هذه